Here's a custom component I've been
working on which closely resembles
a radio group.
To determine what kind of
keyboard support it needs,
I'll check
the Aria Design Patterns guide.
And going to jump down to
Section 11 which lists
all of the various components and
their patterns.
Once we're down here, I'll look for
a component that sort of matches
the one that I'm building.
In this case I can see that there's
a radio button right about here.
So I'll click on that.
And based on the recommendations there
are a number of keyboard handlers that I
know I now need to implement.
Using this guide I'm going to
implement the Down Arrow slash
Right Arrow support in my element.
Now when the user presses the down arrow
we know that our radio group should move
focus to the next radio button It should
select that button and it focuses
is on the last item, then focus
will wrap around to the first item.
To do this, we're going to use
a technique called roving focus.
Roving focus works by
setting tab index to -1 for
all of the children and
then zero on the currently active item.
Our component then uses a keyboard
event listener to determine which
key the user has pressed.
At which point we set tab index
on the next item to zero,
we set to have a next of the previously
focused item to negative one.
We call the focus method of this
new soon to be focused item,
this now moves our focus ring.
And lastly I'm going to just move this
checked attribute down to this element
using SET attribute In this case I'm
using the CSS in my element based on
that checked attribute just style
the state of the radio button.
Now when I reach the bottom of this
list and this last radio is focused and
the user presses the down arrow,
then we're going to wrap back around.
So we'll set tab index to
zero on this top item.
We'll move checked over there or
call focus and
we'll set tab index to negative one
on the previously focused item.
For building complex components running
focus is a really invaluable technique.
So in the next lesson, you're going to
take a crack at implementing it yourself
using the same example.